avec l'histoire du non-cumul la loi qui
va être entré en vigueur pour cette
élection là il y aura beaucoup moins
deux présidents de département est
rappelé aux responsables de départ à
bruno rapide du tout bon
est-ce que c'était déjà le cas à
l'assemblée est-ce que ça va pas être un
manque pour la chambre qui est sortie
elle représenter les territoires et
moins de poids pour saturn et pour les
territoires c'est une difficulté
elle est réelle elle est réglée parce
que je pense qu'aucun gouvernement ne
reviendra sur le cumul donc l' affaire
est entendu on peut en penser ce qu'on
en pense mais cette affaire est entendue
il faut maintenant qu'on s'organise
question estrosi l'évoqué l'autre jour
également il faut que les maires des
grandes villes
les présents département nous soyons
capables de prendre des initiatives
collectives vis-à-vis de l'état et ça
veut dire que la responsabilité qui pèse
sur nos épaules philippe richert pour
les régions françois baroin pour les
départements et moi même et mes
collègues pour les femmes soit baroin
pour les communes et moi et mes
collègues pour les départements faut que
nous ayons maintenant fassions entendre
plus fort notre voix parce qu'avant là
on l'a fait entendre la commission des
lois au sénat à l'assemblée à boire
maintenant il faut qu'on discute
directement avec les parlementaires et
qu'on discute directement plus avec le
gouvernement donc nous avons une
responsabilité supplémentaire dans cette
nouvelle paire comment vous allez faire
alors on va bosser pour parler plus vous
bossez déjà en deux ans par les efforts
pour nous faire attendre
mais on va pas pleurnicher on va faire
des propositions